back this Saturday is the Dana Marshall
Bernstein courage ball benefiting the
Crohn's in Colitis Foundation and I am
very excited to be back as the host this
year but even more excited to have Grant
Hunter who is this year's patient hero
honoree with us today it's good to see
you buddy good to see you too let's talk
about tell everyone what is the Crohn's
and Colitis Foundation so the Crohn's
and class Foundation is a good
foundation they help fundraise money to
help patients like me and Dana Marshall
find a cure to eventually hopefully find
a cure so we won't have to have this
disease to deal with crohn's yeah and
when were you diagnosed with crohn's I
was diagnosed with crohn's in 2017 he
was 13 years old 13 years old and you're
in high school now where'd you go to
High School uh Centennial High School
I'm a senior and you're on the lacrosse
team yes sir and thanks to advances in
medicine and Technology how how is
Crohn's for you right now right now I'm
luckily in remission so I'm able to ski
mountain bike play lacrosse love it yep
I love hearing that so let's talk about
this weekend the courage ball is
happening on Saturday yeah I'm going to
be hosting it look forward to seeing you
again there what can we expect this
weekend so this weekend it's gonna be
good I'm the honored here so I'll give
up and give a speech and hopefully
motivate some other kids and yeah it'll
be good and as the patient hero what
does that mean to you because you've
been through a lot what does that mean
to you to be the honoree this year it
means a lot it helps me to know that I'm
able to give some advice to other people
who need it you know
some people don't know that much about
Crohn's and I'm able to open a new door
for them and understand a little bit
more about it my wife was diagnosed gosh
20 years ago or so and I remember when
she first got I could even spell it I'm
like what disease
people out you educating especially
educating teens and you went to
Washington DC and spoke to lawmakers
about Crohn's and Colitis and research
how was that it was good I was able to
talk to some Senators hopefully able to
persuade them to change a few laws about
some medical stuff so yeah that went
good and because of the Crohn's and
Colitis Foundation research has come so
far which is so far they've done a lot
for us yeah they've hosted Camp Oasis
sent me to DC to go help patients like
me they've done a lot they're raising a
ton of money to help us find a cure so
and this weekend Grant and I were going
to raise more money this weekend at the
courage ball there's a huge silent
auction you can go to their website for
more information Grant thank you for
joining us of course the third annual
courage ball is happening this Saturday
at the Four Seasons Las Vegas for more
information visit courageball Dot